en quelques heures la ville de dès midi
s'est retrouvé sous l'eau au deuxième
jour de la guerre les chars russes
approché qui elle venait qu'à 50 km
l'armée ukrainienne voulait à tout prix
empêcher leur avancée elle a ouvert le
barrage voisin
la majorité des civils avaient déjà fui
mais certains sont restés malgré les
risques
l'eau est montée jusque ici
tout était inondée ça c'est
parce que nous souffrons
si l'on nous compare aux autres
d'ukrainiens pas du tout je ne me
planquer
pour évacuer l'eau la ville ne dispose
que de cette pompe les habitants
comprennent la décision de l'armée mais
après deux mois d'inondations certains
noms peuvent plus
se doit d'être d'accord
l'eau est montée jusqu'au niveau de ma
poitrine
depuis elle est redescendue grâce à la
ponte
mais j'ai dû grimper à la fenêtre
cela m'a détruit les genoux personne
n'est venu nous aider
afin d'éviter que les russes ne puisse
franchir le barrage les militaires
ukrainien s'ils sont positionnés
d'intenses combats l'ont détruit
cet homme a ouvert les vannes pour
inonder la vallée avant l'offensive
de mes preuves
c'était une bonne idée de faire cela
sinon les tanks russes seraient passés
facilement
mais grâce à cela ils sont restés
coincés kiev et rester en sécurité au
cette stratégie d'autres sabotage de
destruction du barrage de 10 me dit ce
n'est pas un cas isolé ici en ukraine
le pont sur lequel je me trouve
actuellement a aussi été détruit et ce
cas pour 300 d'entre 3 100 points qui
menait vers la capitale kiev pour éviter
l' attaque des troupes russes sur la
capitale